R
ANDLEARLY THERE IS AN INVERSE
IQ TEST GOING ON IN TH HIRING
DEPARTMENT AT MSNBC, BUT HERE
ARE THE NEW RULES: IFOU WOULD
LIKE A BIG PUBCLY HELD
COORATION TO PAY ITS TAXES,
THEN YOU ARE A CHI RAPIST,
OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE A RACIST, LIKE
PUTIN Y ARE A FASCIST, BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT ELSE YOU ARE?
ACCORDING TO JOY REID, YOU ARE A
COMMUNIST.
RON DeSANTIS IS "TAKING US
BACK TO THE SOVIET UNION," YOU
E A COMMUNIST IF YOU WANT THE
MPANY TOAY ITS TAXES.
JOY REID WENT TO HARVARD SOE
ARE NOT GOING TO DAGREE WITH
HER BUT WE DID FEEL A MAL
OBLIGATION TO CHECK THAT FACT
BECAUSE IT IS HEAVY CLAIM.
JOININUS LIVE TO CONFIRM OR
DENY THESE CHARGES IS CONRAD
RON DeSANTIS WHO IS ALSO THE
GOVERNOR OF FLORIDA.
GOVERNOR, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
COMING OUT TONIGHT.
I CANNOT TELL WHETHER YOU ARE A
RACIST, COMMUNIST, FASCI, FORWAD
CORPORATN TO PAY ITS TAXES.
HOW WOULD YOU DESCRIBE YOURSELF,
TUCKER, NOT ONLY PAY TAXES, THIS
COMPANY HAD A DE UNLIKE ANY
COMPANY OR ANY INDIVIDUAL IN ALL
OF THE STATE OF FLORIDA,
PROBABLYNYWHERE IN THE
UNITED STATES,HEY WERE
SELF-GOVERNING, THEY HAD
EXTRAORDINAR POWERS, THEY COULD
BUILD NUCAR POWER PLANTS, THEY
DIDN'T HAVEO GO THROUGH
PEITTING PROCESSES, OBVIOUSLY
A LOT OF TAX BENEFITS, SO TT
IS JUST AN APPROPRIATE AND IT IS
CERTAINLY AN APPROPRIATE WHEN
YOU LOOK, AS YOU I THINK DID A
GREAT JOB POINTING OUT, THEY
PLEDGED THEMSELVES TO MOBILIZE
THEIR CONSIDERABLE CORPORATE
RESOURCES OUT OF THE COFFERS OF
THE BURBANK, CALIFORNIA,-BASED
OPERION TO OVERTURN THE RIGHTS
OF PARENTS IN A STA OF FLORIDA
AND EFFECTIVELYOMMANDEER OUR
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS, AND SO THAT
OBVIOUSLY  SOMETHING THAT WE
VERY MUCH OBJECTED TO, AND THEN
YOU ALSO HAVE THOSE VIDEOS THAT
YOU SHOWED WHERE YOU HAVE ALL
THES HIGHER-UPS DISNEY TALKING
ABOU HOW IT WAS THEIR INTENT TO
INDUCTIVE SEXUALITY IN THE
PROGRAMMING THAT GOES TO YOUNG ,
I HAVE A 5-YEAR-OLD, 4-YEAOLD,
AND 2-YEAR-OLD AT HOM TUCKER
AND I WANT THEM TO BE ABLE TO
WATCH CARTOONS WITHOUT HAVING
THE STUFF JAMMED DOWN THEIRTHROS
ORIGINAL, THREE YEARS AGO,
WHENEVER, BUT IT IS CERTALY
APPROPRIATE TO MAKE THEM LIVE
UNDER THE SAME LAWS AS EVERYBODY
ELSE I THE STATE OF FLORIDA.>> A
LITTLE WEIRD COMING FROM PEOPLE
WHO DEVOT THEIR PROGRAMMING TO
DEFENDING "DEMOCRACY," SO YOU
HAVE BEEN ELECTEDY THE VOTERS
OF FLORIDA, YOU ARE STANDING FOR
ELECTION VERY SOON IN NOVEMR,
WE WILL SEEOW YOU DO, BUT YOU
ARE A PRODUCT OF DEMOCRACY.
BOB CHAPEK AND FIREFIGHTER WERE
ELECD BY NOBODY SO WHY
WOULDN'T DEMOCRACY DEFENDERS BE
ON THE SIDE OF THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS ER CORPORATE FIAT?
>> BECAUSE I THINK WHAT THE LEFT
HAS COME TO IS ALL THEY WANT TO
SEE IS POWER EXERCIS AND
ADVANCEDHEIR LEFTIST AGENDA.
YES, THEY USE TO BE HOSTILE TO
BIG CORPORATIONS BECAUSE THEY
PERCEIVE CORPORATIONS AS BEING
POLITICALND THEY WOULD N
SUPPORT THEIR AGENDA.
NOW THEY FIGURED OUTHAT THEY
CAN TRY TO SUBCONTRACT OUT THEIR
LEFTISM TO SOME OF THESEIG
CORPORATIONS AND SOME OF THE
EXECUTIVES WILL CAVE TO THE WOKE
MOB AND BASICALLY DO THE LEFT'S
RTY WORK.
TUCKER, THEY'RE NO GOING TO WIN
ELECTIONS IN FLORIDA IF THEY ARE
ACTUALLY RUNNING ON INJEING
TRANSGENDER IDEOLOGY INTO
SECO GRADE CLASSROOMS AND THEY
OW THAT.
THEIR HOPE WAS GETTING DISNEY
INVOLVED IN THAT WOULD SOMEHOW
GET ME TBACK DOWN FROM SIGNING
THE BILL.
WELL, THAT WAS A BAD JUDGMENT ON
THEIR PART BECSE OF COURSE WE
WEREN'T GOING TO BACK DOWN AN
INCH.
>> Tucker: IT IS LITTLE
WEIRD BECAUSE THERE ARE A BUNCH
OF REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS IN THE
COUNTRY -- YOU AREHE
REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR THAT SITS
OV THE MOST EVENLY DIVIDED
STATE, IF THEY'RE FILED IN STATE
BUT JUST BELY --
OVERWHELMINGLY REPUBLICAN STATES
IN THE WEST LIKE UTAH, THERE
GOVERNORS HAVE NOTONE ANYTHING
LIKE THIS.
THEY HAVE NOFOUGHT BACK AT
ALL.
WHAT IS THAT, DO YOU INK?
>> I DON'T KNOW, THE WAY I VIEW,
YOU HAVEIND OF THE TWITTER
CLASS, YOU HAVE SOME OF THES
PEOPLE, AND THAT IS A DISTORTED
VIEW OF REALITY, A YOU
ACTUALLY NEED TO TALK TO PEOPLE
WHO AREN'T AAYS ON THOSE
OUTLETS,ND LISTEN TO WHAT THEY
HAVE TO SAY, AND I CAN TL YOU,
THEY DO NOT WANT THIS WOKE
GARBAGE INUR SOCIETY.
THEY DON'T WANT MEN TO BE
DENIED THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PARTICIPE IN SPORTS.
THEY DON'T WANT TO SEE THEIR
KIDS GO TO KINRGARTEN AND HAVE
THIS STUFF JAMMED DOWN THEIR
THROATS, SO I JUST STAND WITH
THE PEOPLE, A LOT OFEDIA AND
BIG CORPORATIONS, BUT AT THE E
OF THE DAY I THI